hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna keep working on our react native
web math game before I get started with
code I'm gonna go to a live chat to see
out everybody hey C cool just a lot of
hellos no questions yet so that's it's
cool if you haven't joined in before
this is how it goes I'll set a timer for
25 minutes I'll do some coding and then
after that is up I'll go to the live
chat on the answer some questions and
then I'll just keep going back and forth
with with the timer and then answering
questions today it's gonna be a little
bit shorter than normal because I have a
meeting scheduled in 59 minutes so you
gotta be finished I have everything set
up for the meeting right next to me on
another laptop so we can go right up to
that time but I can't go over so let's
get started I'm gonna set my timer it's
just a Pomodoro timer and just want to
let everybody know we do have a github
repo for this project so if you want to
check out the code it's there I update
it at the end of every stream I'm gonna
paste that into live chat it's also
available in the description if you're
wondering why we're using react native
web or exactly what this project is
about you can check out some of the
previous streams so this is the fifth
stream in the series okay I'm gonna
start the app using running yarn start
all right so right now basically we have
an app and this is the the hero
character is this a square here and
these are the enemies of the the red
squares so you get it right a red square
disappears if you get all the red
squares to disappear you win if you get
it wrong then the red square is keep
appearing and right now it's set up to
keep appearing until you hit 6 and then
it stops at 6 so right now we just have
edition so what I'd like to add today is
a subtraction option so that the user
could go onto subtraction and select
whether or not they want addition or
subtraction or maybe even a mix so let's
see if if we can get that incorporated
today probably what I'll do first is
just add it in I'm not going to worry
about the UI element to select whether
or not you which game mode you want
let's just get the game of working first
and if we have time we can add in the
the toggle or the selector okay so
here's what I have so far I'm using
Visual Studio code I'm gonna try to get
rid of as much as I can to give us room
for for the actual code right now we're
doing our our problem
where is it
oh here it is so we're checking if
something is correct right here in our
check answer and we're using the the
plus sign right so in order to add this
other game let's see all right here's
what I'm thinking right now we could do
a switch statement and inside the switch
statement we set the value of what
correct is and we just changed the the
the operator right the I guess that's
what this would be called the math
operator so from addition and
subtraction and later on we can add
multiplication and division let's go
with that for now maybe have a better
idea at some point but I think that
should work and I'm a big fan of the
switch statement I've always liked it so
yeah the only option I could think of is
is actually making this part a variable
the the operator but I don't know if we
can do that yeah I don't think that'll
that will work so every time I do a
switch statement I always do the same
thing I go to mdn and I copy and paste
or switch statement example because I
don't use them often enough to memorize
the syntax
so javascript switch and mdn is one of
the first links that comes up I just
copy this and paste it here and then we
can change it so let's pass in yeah when
we do check answer it let's let's pass
in operator okay and we'll pass an
operator into the switch statement so
whatever our cases here would be if the
operator is addition or subtraction and
while we're at it let's just add
multiplication okay and I guess we could
also add another case for division
we're not gonna actually create any of
the logic for that today I don't think
so but we'll have it there and then in
here instead of a console log we're
gonna add this so let's say we're just
going to define correct up there and
then down here we'll actually do the set
the value right so okay so for addition
right everything's the same for
subtraction we're gonna copy and paste
that and then we're just gonna change
the plus sign to the minus sign and for
multiplication and subtraction I guess
or multiplication and division I guess
we could just do this like while we're
at it while we're in here doing this
maze we'll just put these in so have
multiplication and division okay and
then we will have a default which this
will if if something gets passed in that
is not covered in any of these cases
it'll just go to the default and for now
I'll just say I'll just say not an
option this will just log to the console
not really worried about what it says
yeah so now we can get rid of this so
which should happen what I hope will
happen is when we call check answer now
we will pass in whether we want it to be
addition subtraction multiplication or
division
and then based on that we will check to
see what it the correct answer is hmm
sorry I didn't have any caffeine
yesterday so I was hoping I would get
some automatic styling here but I'm not
getting it so I'm gonna have to do a
little bit this formatting myself but
that looks terrible I guess I don't have
my linting set up correctly yet for for
this computer so maybe that's why either
that or as some sort of syntax error I
guess we'll find out all right
everything else should remain the same
the only other thing that we want to
change here is the display right so we
are displaying the the math problem we
have here right so we definitely don't
want to display that you think
how am I gonna do this
all right so this is just going to be a
string that's gonna have the the
operator okay I guess we could say
operator and then by default love
addition and then down here depending on
what gets passed in we could set the
state to a different operator so let's
say this set States operator and we
could say plus here we'll say let's just
keep putting these in here cover all the
cases so operator here is subtraction
multiplication and division
[Music]
yeah these these operators might be a
little bit different than what children
are used to seeing like in school they
would probably see like an X instead of
this and maybe like an actual division
sign I'm gonna leave it like this for
now and later on we could come back in
maybe change that out after I maybe test
it out with with my kids and see if they
they understand what's happening and
then down here we can change this right
so that now it will of this state's
operator all right so let's save that
and just see if we have any errors all
right hey no errors that I can see we'll
do we'll inspect the page here and go to
wow this is so zoomed in let me zoom out
a bit I want you all to be able to see
it but I think that was a bit too big
each child in a list should have any key
prop okay so we don't have a unique key
prop in one of our lists that's that's
fine for now
it's probably where we're adding these
in all right so that works let's just
verify that our answer checker still
works so four plus six should be ten not
an option oh you know what we forgot to
pass in when we call answer checker so
where am i doing that
I think I'm calling it maybe from down
and here yet this thought check answer
let's just say we're gonna pass in
addition actually let's let's make this
a let's pass in this state's thoughts
mode well so this state mode and then
mode for now is edition okay
now we'll see if that works
not an option
did I not pass it in I see a lot of
stuff in the chat so hang in there we've
got about 10 more minutes and then I'll
go over to the chat let me check reacts
quickly see what the value of the state
is edition okay so say Edition but what
about alright let's put in a breakpoint
so I want to see what is coming in here
is the operator
why is it for the very point there there
we go okay undefined I wonder if
maybe I need to put this in
all right let's see no that's not gonna
work
so dude what am I doing wrong here this
state
is it I think that I don't have access
to the right this you is that my problem
see
okay
I'm not sure if anybody's said anything
about this in the chat so
let's see
let's do
[Music]
all right if we do this and we can call
this check answer this the states mode I
know that I have access to state here so
I can call handle submit by to see if
that works had shown instances you know
much easier this would be with react
Oaks actually you know what the the
react native update that has react hooks
in it came out on like Tuesday I think
so we probably could use hooks I'll just
need to update the version of react that
we're using alright so maybe I'll try to
do that before the next stream but let's
let's get well I guess we can keep our
breakpoint just to make sure it's
working okay alright doesn't really
matter operator okay
edition
okay let's unpause that
uh-uh it's still not working I think
maybe the problem was not what I thought
it was
hmm
okay so we saw that operator was
addition my spelling addition the same
way like let's let's check the basic
Spade alright so it should be passing in
the string addition let's find a ad D by
T oh I do that I have a typo typo and I
think like everything that I just did
was unnecessary it's funny how you can
look at that and not realize that you
had a typo all right yeah that works
okay Wow okay so that works now if if we
change it for right now let's change it
manually from addition - subtraction
okay and we'll manually change this for
now and now let's see we have
subtraction so let's see if it works
yeah it works
awesome
cool now edition that is pretty simple
to deal with when we get into some of
these other modes especially for like
the very basic level of small children
or just learning math we might want to
think about putting in some some rules
into our logic that will prevent things
like the the last problem I think that
popped up on the screen at 0 minus
something right small children are gonna
know about negative numbers is so that's
that shouldn't be presented to them so
we may want to have some sort of check
you know when we generate these numbers
that the result isn't a negative number
or then when we go to division we might
want to check to see like we only want
whole numbers all right we don't want
decimal numbers so we'll have to keep
that in mind I'm not gonna go into that
on today's stream but that's definitely
gonna be something that I think will
need to be in place otherwise you know
the game will be just way too hard for
the target audience which is you know
children that are just starting out you
know learning math alright I got about a
minute left on the timer but I'm gonna
go ahead and just take the break now and
go to the live chat and start answering
some questions all right so I'm
scrolling all the way to the top and
just go as quickly as I can down through
I'll probably skip a lot of the comments
and just get to the question since I'm
running on a tight schedule today
Milano asked if I could fix night but I
have no idea how nightbot works so I
don't know hmm excuse me
Stark asks about Starks music asked
about a super chat option we don't do
super chat as far as I know on a free
killcam channel so it's not it wouldn't
really be up to me anyway
I am I am just one among many many
volunteers for free code camp
okay Daniel did confirm that you can't
make operators variables Daniel is also
excited about switch statement it's
awesome
rose versus have you used adonis js4
back-end API I have not I have not had
no experience with adonis what
maybe if anybody has any info about
adonis and what we what's good about it
on us why would I want to use it on us
let me know alright John Hanson has a
JavaScript question is it better to
define a variable global scope or within
an argument if there's a callback it
calls another function do you need to
pass that variable on with it
yeah I would say in general do not
globally scope a variable unless you
absolutely have to so the default should
be not to globally scope things you want
local scope and if it has a callback oh
whoa I'm sorry I'm yawning so much out
of yeah do you need to pass it with a
callback I don't know I mean I'm
thinking if like when you chain things
with dot then you you have to pass
things but now I like I don't know if we
had a callback I think you would but I'm
not 100% sure are like block scoped
variables
accessible to a callback function I
guess that's the question and I'm not
I'm sure
Johnny Hansen says react is often
thought of as an app or components each
containing their own functions global or
local scope is often I questions okay
yet yeah in the in the context of react
I would say yeah like if try to keep
still try to keep everything local if
you can but if it needs to be accessible
from different components then you know
then global is a way I guess to go with
it
see
okay there was a question but it was
actually for somebody else in the chat
so I'm gonna skip over that
so there's a question from jag on what
is my first step to becoming a pen
tester I guess start learning how to do
it and then do the testing on sites or
systems that you have permission to test
on
so pen test is penetration testing so
it's like almost like like hacking when
you have permission to hack a company
right so you're testing to see how hard
it would be for or how easy it would be
for hackers to get into their system you
know basically so yeah I don't know a
lot of the details about how to become a
penetration tester but just in general
I'd say like you know you would want to
start learning about it and working with
it there may be special certifications
that you would get for that that I I
don't know about so I would check into
that
Django and says I want to make a fortune
doing bug bounties okay if that's your
goal then you probably don't need to be
certified just learn how to do it and
start trying to find bugs it's almost to
the bottom of the chat I'm just gonna go
ahead and finish up with whatever
questions are in here before we start up
again
okay there's actually no more questions
it was just comments and replies to
previous questions so if you're
interested in the replies and everything
you can certainly check out the live
chat in the right now or in the
recording to save time I'm not gonna
read them off
all right cool let's I'm not gonna set
another poem over timer since I'm gonna
have to finish up probably before this
timer will go off anyway but now that we
have this and the ability to change our
modes in here let's try to create some
sort of UI element that will allow a
user to change the modes
so remember eventually we're probably
gonna have at least four different
options addition subtraction
multiplication division so we could have
I mean we could do like an input let's
let's see what react native gives us in
terms of inputs here we go here's our
components a picker let's see what
maybe this would be the best thing yeah
let's try that let's try this see how it
looks
so I find it helpful sometimes when I
want to add something in react native I
start thinking like how am I gonna build
this out without realizing that rack
native already comes with components
that are like pre-made so it's good to
try to go with the pre-made ones
especially if you want to create these
apps for different platforms because
they were already made with with that in
mind whereas if you were to try to build
your own it may not work like you think
it would work like me coming from a web
development background I would tend
towards like hey I'm just gonna build it
like I would for the web but that might
not work with Android or iOS or whatever
else you're you're gonna build for okay
okay so this does render iOS and Android
that's good because I see there's
another one called picker iOS but I
think this is the way to go and it'll it
should work for both
all right so let's put this in here for
now I'm not gonna worry about where it
goes I'm just gonna put it in there we
actually do have to import picker right
so we can input that from react native
picker and let's just see how it looks
first cool yeah this is actually perfect
I mean it's not the best looking thing
ever but it does what we want it to do
so let's just use this as the basis and
we'll just see if we can toggle between
addition and subtraction all right so
just based on what we have here let's
see so we have a non value change okay
and we can pass in the item value and
the item index is so let's give this a
label of addition I spelled it wrong
again ad di tion okay and let's say
subtraction and you know what let's I
want to make this
even more clear for children what it is
we're gonna we're gonna put in the
little symbols here right
subtraction okay so now we're passing we
can set state - yeah actually so we can
let's set mode to be the item value and
all right so this works for item value
and then are we setting okay good so
we're setting what this is going to be
here
all right I don't know if this is
competitive update we're gonna have a
problem let me let me just do it and
then that way everybody will see the
problem if you don't already see it but
let's save it all right so right now we
have addition and subtraction so let's
check our state right now and just see
what happens I need all right okay you
should be able to see it now all right
so here's our state our mode of
subtraction now our mode is addition all
right but the problem is right now like
it doesn't change this right so would it
so we need to make sure that the
operator also changes so let's go back
here and say
oh yeah notice okay I really want to be
able to pass in like another value let's
go back to the react the yeah the
easiest way to do this would be if I
could pass in both values and set the
the mode there so let's go to the
documentation and just see what options
we have so on value change now it looks
like we just have it just has two
parameters item values the value prop I
wonder what the value could be though
like let's try this but does the value
actually have to be a string I don't
know let's see if we can make it
something else okay so maybe we can make
the value an object right toward the
shot right so we could say mode addition
operator + let's say that see we get and
in if that is the case we can then say
operator equals item value oops
value dot operator and this would be
item value dot
mode and I should probably copy and
paste that otherwise we'll definitely
get an error because it'll be looking
for these and obviously won't be there
subtraction to give it a minus sign all
right okay each other
invalid prop value supplied to picker
item okay so can't pass in objects I
guess it has to be a string yeah we
could see right it's it's not it's not
working it's not passing that okay let's
see all right so let's forget that idea
is worth a shot now I know that you
can't pass that so I do have another
idea I was just kind of hoping that I
wouldn't have to do this okay that's all
back to normal so we say on value change
we are for sure changing the the mode
whoops not back to normal completely
there we go
okay so we're for sure changing the mode
we drew this as state mode item value
but also
what we could do is alright we could
make handle mode handle mode picker and
then in that case we could have passing
a value to this and within here we could
have another switch statement which this
is why I didn't want to do this because
it's it's getting a little ridiculous
with all these switch statements but
this will work at some point this is
definitely going to it'll be worth it to
say maybe like do a refactor but
basically like we already have all logic
we need in here to do what we want to do
where you can just take this out right
and we're setting the state of sending a
state here and we could say mode and the
mode is equal to Val
right the value that we're passing in
and I forgot the other part of the arrow
function right
we're not Val there we go okay so you're
passing in Val here and
right so this is this is really all we
would need to do to make that work and
if it works I'll explain it more about
what's happening for its way to see if
it actually works first so we'll call
this the handle mode picker and we'll
pass it item value all right let's check
it out now okay so we do need to handle
like what what is gonna be the default
when we well I guess we'll just change
the fallback to dish all right so we got
subtraction now let's let's try addition
first see if that works
okay that worked properly 1 minus 2 is
negative 1 and then let's try something
that doesn't work for sure let's go back
to addition and okay cool
so this does work I do want to go back
and change the default to match what the
default would be in our picker okay so
here's what I did and here's why it
works so before let's see so we had it
working so that it would change the mode
but we really needed to change the mode
and the operator right because otherwise
the user would not be able to see the
correct operator on the the problem like
they would potentially they could like
select subtraction but it would still
show addition down here right so that
would be very confusing so that's why we
we couldn't just change the state
you know right from from our picker
right the first attempt was to try to
use an object here you can't it's the
the type assigned to this and by react
native is evidently just string so
that's why we had to go up here and
create a method to handle what to do
whenever the user changes that input so
in this case we're setting the state of
the mode and operator so hopefully that
makes sense so much time we have okay
I'm gonna go back to the chat now so
essentially we we have accomplished what
we said we were going to at the
beginning which is we put in another
mode subtraction it works the logic
works it's not perfect yet right
remember we want to make it so that
negative numbers would never be an
answer so we still need to add that in
but we also and I wasn't sure we get
this far we also added a UI element so
that a user could select which mode they
they wanted to use so not bad and we've
already set up most of what we need for
the other modes for multiplication and
division so really it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be that much more difficult to
do that we'd pretty much just have to
add some more values to the picker and
we would then have multiplication and
division so not not too bad in fact I
want to try that out really because I
think we did put everything in that we
need so let's let's try that so all we
need to do here is just we'll copy and
paste that and change a few things
multiplication and division
okay let's check it out
all right cool multiplication this
should be zero
yeah let's put in a wrong answer okay
let's try a division all right
definitely not this is gonna be harder
till I get one that is really easy
Oh what happened here oh I see well
since we added this element in the
screen is kind of compressed so we're
not getting those lines in between one
that I could do in my head
5/2 can I do this one it's just like
point four point four
oh I don't know what I was I was
thinking of the percentage that five is
of - nevermind okay all right so we we
did get one right so it division works
so all of them do work so we've actually
added three modes and really it wasn't
that much extra work cool
all right let me check will do a git
commit and we'll check this into the
repo and then I'll go to the chat so I
want to make sure you all have access to
this code so we get status to see what's
changed make sure it was just what we
wanted which like I thought just one
file because we are only just working in
one file right now but do a git commit
we use a.m. as the flag so we'll add and
commit at the same time and then we'll
also have a message to put in so adds a
mug in this photo everything Mose in
selector all right that works and I'm
gonna push that
and now all that code is available on
github so check that out we'll do a
little refresh
see we have five commits now alright so
latest commit was 18 seconds ago that's
our commit so all our codes here you can
check it out in the github repo and here
it is feel free to submit a pull request
if you think that there's something you
really want to do or submit an issue if
there if you don't want to actually code
it but you just want to give me some
something you think should be added to
the project I added one earlier that's
just a reminder like hey I need to add a
readme instead of this default thing
that comes with create react app so
anyway that's it for the coding let me
try to answer as many questions as I can
in the next two minutes
okay
I John asks John kill kill ad kill
adidas I don't know say that I'm sorry
John says that they're new and where
would be a good place to begin I
definitely say try free code camp org I
learned so much when I was starting out
and I I still go to freaking org so
let's try that out
hi Michael noticed that the addition
label was spelled wrong so thanks for
noticing too bad I didn't look over and
see that John says that picker needs
some CSS style yeah it definitely does
yeah John says Jesse can't spell his
only weakness if only that was my only
weakness that I would I would be okay
with it
alright I'm skipping through and just
trying to find questions right now so if
I don't see your comment apologies we
have a question why do you prefer vs
code over for example webstorm I don't
know I've never used webstorm so maybe I
would like it if I tried it but I've
never tried it I do I really like visual
studio code though also had a question
does he actually read the chat yes in
fact I do Michael asked if I could pass
an array actually that would have been
good to try so but I I don't know maybe
we can try that at some point
michael says you could send a comma
delimited string and then split it that
that also could have been an option that
would have worked I should have looked
over at the chat then John says does
react native allow the use of ref yeah
you you can use ref at least in the web
I've gotten it to work in the web
version of react native web so I have
not tried to use it along like an
emulator for iOS or anything like that
if question Tyler says is JavaScript
your language of choice yeah yeah
javascript is my primary language
although I have used other languages
before and I'm currently learning more
about c-sharp because the back end of
the project I'm working on at my normal
job is written in C sharp so but
definitely JavaScript is my go-to if you
told me to build an app as fast as I
could I would use JavaScript Tyler also
said and follow-up to that do you need
coffee yeah for sure
michael says addition is actually still
spelled wrong Oh seriously
I still spell it wrong what the heck is
wrong with me why can't I spell it it's
spelled wrong right there no oh man
alright somebody open an issue and tell
me to learn how to spell or just fix it
we'll get to that next time I can't
believe I can't spell edition but anyway
so I am so for those of you who may be
Catholic you know that is Lent right now
and if you're not familiar with that
it's a time where we usually like make
some sort of sacrifice so I decided that
I would only be drinking water for Lent
and so that means no coffee for me oh
it's been pretty hard it's been over a
week now and I have I have still a long
time to go but I feel okay it is like
it's rough in the mornings it is really
but anyway alright okay I have one
minute till my meeting starts so I have
to go now thank you all so much for for
watching and for all your advice in the
chat I'll try to pay more attention to
the next time and
[Applause]
I don't know this is good we did we did
a good job even though I couldn't spell
I think I'm happy with how much we get
done on the stream today so anyway I
appreciate you all being here again
thank you so much and have a great
weekend